THE SINGLE GREATEST THREAT TO
THE HISTORY OF UNITED STATES AS
TRUE.
STEVE BANNON IS THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF STRATEGIST IS
ALSO THE HOST OF THE WAR ROOM
AND AS WE JUST TOLD YOU HE'S
JUST BEEN CONVICTED OF TWO
CRIMES THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US.
YOU CAN KIND OF HELP BUT NOTICE
THAT YOU WERE CONVICTED OF A
CRIME WHICH IS NOT ACTUALLY A
CRIME MOST THE TIME IN
WASHINGTON OR EVER.
WITHIN THE SAME 24-HOUR PERIOD
GUY WHO TRIED TO MURDER A
CANDIDATE IN NEW YORK WAS
RELEASED WITH NO BAIL WOULD BE
TO MAKE OF THESE TWO EVENTS
OCCURRING THE SAME DAY?
>> AS YOU CAN TELL THE DEMOCRATS
ARE COMPLETELY LAWLESS AND LOOK
HOW THEY RUN THIS COMMITTEE.
THIS NO RANKING MEMBER, THE SNOW
MINORITY COUNSEL IS THE
TRADITIONAL HEARINGS THAT HAVE
GALVANIZED NATION IN THE PAST
TUCKER I THINK IT'S ONE THE
REASONS THAT HAS A REALLY HAVE
THAT BIG AN IMPACT.
THEY INTERVIEWED THE PEOPLE ON
THE TRIAL I THINK ON THE SIDE OF
THE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE TO DO
EVEN KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
YOUR SHOW PEOPLE LIKE DARREN
BEATTY AND REVOLVER IF DONE
ACTUALLY MORE ORIGINAL REPORTING
OF WHAT WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM LOOK.
WE NEED A COMMISSION OR
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY 6.
TO BE WITH THE NEW CONGRESS,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE
IF GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
INTELLIGENCE FAILURES GET SOME
GUY INVOLVEMENT INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE PENTAGON
AND NATIONAL GUARD.
ALL OF IT.
ALL OF THIS WE HAVE TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF.
AND PEOPLE GONNA GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT INTO THE FACT OF
SOME THE TESTIMONIALS GIVEN BY
STAFFERS IN MY TRIAL.
WE WON WANTED DECISION-MAKERS TO
COME OVER AND ASKED TO GO ON
RECORD UNDER OATH AND SAY
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE AND
THEY WOULDN'T THEY HAD BEHIND
THEIR PRIVILEGE WAS THAT WHEN
ALLOW ME TO THEN JUDGE THE TIME
FROM EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
>> Tucker: I SPENT MY WHOLE
LIFE IN WASHINGTON I SEE A LOT
OF ACRIMONIOUS DEBATES BUT THE
IDEA THAT YOU WOULD SEND SOMEONE
TO PRISON BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
HIS VIEWS IS NO ALLEGATION THE
ORGANIZE JANUARY 6 IT'S FULLY
INSANE THEY DON'T LIKE YOUR
POLITICS THAT YOUR ATTITUDE AND
THE TRY TO SEND YOU TO JAIL DID
YOU THINK I DIDN'T THINK THIS
WOULD HAPPEN A START THERE.
DID YOU THINK THIS COULD HAPPEN?
>> I THINK IT HAPPENS MEMBER
THESE GUYS ALL THOUGHT THAT
THERE BEEN A CHANGE CHINA THE
CHINESE, AND HIS PARTY ARE TAKEN
ON THE ASPECT OF THE
AUTHORITARIAN STATE AND STATE
CAPITALISM COMBINED.
THIS IS IN THE LEADS THAT RUN
THIS COUNTRY THIS IS EXACTLY HOW
THEY WANT TO RUN IT REMEMBER.
TUCKER I'M NOT NEW TO THIS I'VE
SPENT MORE THAN ANY TRUMP
OFFICIAL INTENSE BEING A WITNESS
PRICING 30 HOURS IN THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE THE
SENATES INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
BY ALEX BIRO HERE HAD DAVID SEAN
I TOP LAWYERS AND ONE EVEN AND
WHEN I COULD RELY ON ON THE
OPINION OF MY LAWYER.
HERE THE TOOK AWAY EVERY
POSSIBLE DEFENSE AND ANYONE CAN
HAVE A DEFENSE OF LAW.
SO WE DIDN'T EVEN PUT UNDER THE
FENCE WE HAD THE OPENING OPEN
ARGUMENT IN A CLOSING ARGUMENT.
THIS IS WHERE THEY'RE GOING YOU
DOCUMENT A BETTER THAN ANYBODY
BUT NO, PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS JUST ONE
FIGHT AN ENTIRE PROCESS AND
THAT'S WHY AT LIZ CHENEY'S
DEFEATED A COUPLE WEEKS IN
WYOMING BY THEIR REPUBLICAN
PARTY BY CONSERVATIVES AND BY
MEGA AND THEN LATER YORTY HAVE
THEM OUT WITH ANOTHER MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE PEOPLE WHO RETIRED
WE MUST HAVE A SWEEPING VICTORY
IN THE HOUSE.
AND THEN REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
HAVE THE STONES PUT ON A REAL
HEARING AND BY THE WAY BUT
DEMOCRATS HAVE A RANKING MEMBER
OF THEM HAVE A COUNSEL AND JUST
GET TO IT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE
DONE IN YOUR SHOW ALONE IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS WITH THE PUBLIC AS A
NO FOR THE GOOD OF THE SYSTEM
THIS HAS TO HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: IN THE MEANTIME
YOU'VE JUST BEEN CONVICTED.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT GOING TO
JAIL?
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT YOU WOULD
BE SELF SAFE THERE FOR EXAMPLE?
>> FIRST OFF IF I GO TO JAIL I
WILL GO TO JAIL I WILL NEVER
BACK OFF SPENT EIGHT YEARS AS A
NAVAL OFFICER I'VE COMMITTED MY
LIFE TO THIS PROGRAM TO GET IT
DONE I WILL NEVER BACK OFF I
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND I'M NOT BACKING
UP 1 INCH.
IF I GO TO JAIL SO BE IT LOOK
WITH A LONG APPEALS PROCESS
ANDY McCARTHY DID A GOOD HIT
ON FOX EARLIER TODAY I THINK THE
LAWS WITH US A NUMBER OF
SITUATIONS AND I THINK SOME OF
THIS IS REALLY TO BE ADJUDICATED
MAY BE EVEN HIGHER THAN THE
OTHER COURTS AND FEELING VERY
CONFIDENT THAT WE ARE HUNDRED%
RIGHT OF THE LAW GONNA FIGHT
THIS ALL THE WAY AND THIS IS THE
ONLY BATTLE IN FIGHTING COVERING
ON EVERY ASPECT LOOK THERE
TRYING TO SHUT DOWN THE CHINA
THROW OFF FOX ANCHORS THE COMING
FOR EVERYBODY AND PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND RIGHT NOW IT'S AN
IDEOLOGICAL WAR AND WE CANNOT
LOSE THE FATE OF THE COUNTRY IS
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
AND PEOPLE JUST WANT TO GO ON
VACATION AND SAY HEY ALL GET
SORTED OUT THAT'S FINE.
BUT THEY ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF FIGHTERS OUT THERE
THAT THEY WERE KNOCKED BACK DOWN
ONE ENGINE I'M NOT GONNA BACK
OUT DOWN 1 INCH AT ALL.
>> Tucker: DID YOU THINK THAT
DURING THE COURSE OF THIS TRIAL
THAT MAYBE YOU SHOULD CALL ERIC
HOLDER?
BOTH OF THEM LIVE IN WASHINGTON
AND SAY HOW DID YOU BEAT THIS?
WHAT'S THE SECRET SAUCE HERE?
>> THEY ARE IN POWER AND ALSO
LET'S BE HONEST THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE BEEN CONTROLLED OPPOSITION
THAT'S WHAT HAS THE CHANGE.
THIS NOVEMBER WE HAVE TO DELIVER
A CRUSHING BLOW TO THIS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY APPARATUS.
BUT THEN WE HAVE TO REALLY
GOVERN IT.
I MEAN GOVERNMENT ON OFFENSE.
EVERY COMMITTEE AND THE HOUSE
HAS TO BE AN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE TO GO AFTER THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHICH
IS A LEGITIMATE YOU CAN THAT
THEY ARE ILLEGITIMATE LIKE HOW
THEY MOCK US TO THEIR FACE.
LOOK ON THE CHINESE, HIS PARTY
HAS ABSOLUTELY NO RESPECT.
THEY UNDERSTAND THEIR
ILLEGITIMATE, WE HAVE TO GET IN
THERE IN JANUARY EVERY COMMITTEE
HAS THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
WE HAVE TO HAVE A REAL JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING TO GET TO THE STAFFERS
NOW AND SEE ABOUT THE LIZA
MR. PRESENTATION THAT THEY PUT A
NATIONAL TELEVISION TO DEFAME
PEOPLE.
I WAS TOLD A JANUARY 6 STAFF
RIGHT NOW PRESERVE YOUR
DOCUMENTS.
THIS COULD BE A REAL COMMITTEE
AND THIS IS GONNA BE BACK BY
REPUBLICAN GRASSROOT BROKERS
SAME WE WANT TO GET THE BOTTOM
OF THIS FOR THE GOOD OF THE
NATION.
OF THEM EVERYTHING THAT WENT ON.
ALL THE INTELLIGENCE REPORTS
EXACTLY WHAT WENT ON WHAT WAS
INVOLVED FBI ASSETS INVOLVEMENT
LOOK JUST GO GET A REVOLVER,
TUCKER CARLSON SHALL RIGHT THERE
ALONE WITH YOU ALL TYPE OF
INQUIRIES WE HAVE TO GET TO OF.
>> Tucker: IF REPUBLICANS WIN
IF THE WONDER IS EVEN WORTH IT?
I'LL LET YOU IN AND THEN FIGHT
THOSE GUYS.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON
TONIGHT OF ALL